unas consideraciones que tener con
respecto a la fuerza de voluntad me
imagino yo que aquí más de uno debe
tener una dificultad para ejercer la
fuerza de voluntad imagino yo que
ante un objetivo una meta de pronto
surgen pensamientos negativos
pensamientos críticos
nos apoyamos
muchas veces ocurre que tenemos que
decidir entre
hacer algo me responsabilizo o bien me
quedo y lo casting o no hago nada al
respecto
la fuerza de voluntad se define como la
capacidad humana para esforzarse lo
suficiente para conseguir un objetivo o
una meta
y estamos acostumbrados a hacerlo de una
manera castigador a una manera
abrumadora no es vemos este objetivo
vemos esta meta como una carga como que
requiere de mucho esfuerzo requiere de
que el camino va a ser muy sufrido y no
voy a poder llegar hasta donde yo quiero
llegar y cumplir lo que yo quiero
cumplir
y la invitación que tengo yo hoy día con
ustedes es hacer lo contrario sino más
bien verlo aproximarse a su objetivo su
meta de una manera mucho más armónica
mucho más amistosa entonces ver el
objetivo ver la meta como un aliado de
ustedes porque esa meta que ustedes
quieren conseguir
algo que a ustedes le va a dar un
bienestar y es que si toman esa decisión
si alguna vez pensaron en eso en la
decisión que han querido tomar es porque
para ustedes es importante entonces muy
profundamente debe tener algo de
importancia para ustedes
a partir del 2011 de mercancía
ecológicos association realiza una
encuesta para interesarse más sobre el
tema de la voluntad y se dan cuenta que
hay muchas personas que están
conscientes de su estilo de vida poco
saludable que presentan sedentarismo y
que además tienen malos hábitos y estas
personas también justifican diciendo que
no tienen la fuerza de voluntad
suficiente que no cuentan con el estado
de ánimo ni tampoco con las estrategias
adecuadas para hacer algún cambio
hoy día les vengo a presentar tres casos
que en realidad son tres factores que
influyen en la fuerza de voluntad
el primero el autocontrol el segundo el
manejo del autocontrol y el tercero la
importancia que tiene que tener el
objetivo la meta para usted es el
significado y el sentido que tiene que
tiene que tener
con respecto al primer caso tenemos acá
la persona que se autorregula versó la
persona que es caprichosa entendiendo
que la persona que se autorregula era
una persona que premedita que es capaz
de ver sus fortalezas y sus debilidades
internas como también las oportunidades
y amenazas externas que se le presentan
y la persona caprichosa como entenderla
como la persona que no puede postergar
la satisfacción inmediata sino que más
bien e impulsivamente tiene que ir tras
una cosa un objeto y estás tratando de
saciar una falta una necesidad un vacío
lo que quiero decir es que hay una más
ansiosa de por medio walter mayol
doctorado de la universidad de colombia
realiza la primera prueba en niños
llamada the mars me down test y en esta
prueba lo que él concluye finalmente es
que hay personas que ejercen el
autocontrol y personas que no ahora esto
no quiere eso no quiero que suene
determinante sino que más bien el
autocontrol es algo que se puede
desarrollar y no es algo que como les
digo que sea determinante a continuación
les quiero mostrar el vídeo
[Música]
aunque se vea
wait
[Música]
créame
i
[Música]
ok
creo
[Música]
i
enero
[Música]
bueno yo imagino que más de alguno de
ustedes se siente identificado con este
vídeo escuche bastantes risas y lo
importante de este es el margen del
texto
entonces a continuación quiero señalar
que lo que concluyen pero antes de decir
que esto es que se realizan un
seguimiento a la edad de los 14 y a los
40 años con estos niños no con los niños
del vídeo sino que en la prueba real y
lo que
se realiza un seguimiento a partir de
realizar las pruebas de
de autocontrol en adultos
y finalmente concluyen que las personas
que ejercen el autocontrol tienden a
rendir mejor académicamente manejar
mejor la concentración manejar el estrés
muestran autocontrol en situaciones
frustrantes y tienen una mayor capacidad
para planificar y organizarse
el segundo caso es de la persona
aplicada versus la persona autoexigente
un poco proactiva entendiendo que la
persona aplicada lleva un ritmo adecuado
de es capaz de darse ciertos momentos de
distensión de dispersión de relajo
y en la medida que va cumpliendo sus
objetivos se siente bien consigo mismo
mientras que la persona autoexigente un
poco proactiva es lo contrario sino que
más bien no se conforma con su desempeño
está constantemente estresado con que
tiene que rendir y tiene que rendir
mejor y no está satisfecho por ende no
disfruta y generalmente wright
baumeinster doctorado de la universidad
de florida realiza un experimento donde
en una sala hace pasar a algunos
participantes y esta sala tenía la
particularidad de que tenía un aroma a
galletas recién horneadas entonces
algunos participantes le hace de
un plato con rábanos y a otros con
galletas y para posteriormente
realizarle es una prueba de resistencia
un rompecabezas complejo y se da cuenta
que las personas que habían comido
galletas rendían mejor que las personas
que habían comido rábanos concluyendo
roy que las personas que se resisten
mucho ejercen mucho este autocontrol lo
drenan para posteriores eventos entonces
de igual manera que si fuese un músculo
cierto cuando trabajamos un músculo este
va a presentar fatiga entonces lo ideal
cierto en este caso lo que quiero
evidenciar es que debe ser equilibrado
el siguiente caso es de la persona que
complace a los demás versos la persona
que satisface su motivación sus
objetivos sus metas
la persona que complace a los demás por
lo general no es no está contenta con
consigo misma se está haciendo felices a
otros entonces usted está constantemente
insatisfecho porque su vida no tiene
sentido o sea qué sentido tiene estar
cumpliendo lo que los demás quieran no
mientras que la persona que realiza su
motivación su objetivo se siente
realizada y más bien tiene un sentido de
vida
marc mi doctorado de la universidad
dejado ni y sus colegas al estudiar esto
concluyen que las personas que ejercen
el autocontrol a partir de terceros
agotan más fácilmente este recurso y
luego lo que concluyen es que en la
medida que ustedes a nosotros todos
tengamos una creencia un pensamiento
fuerte de base por ejemplo pensar que mi
voluntad es ilimitada y que con ella
puedo llegar hasta donde sea hasta el
fin del universo por ejemplo ese
pensamiento al momento de que yo de
cuando ejerza el autocontrol este
pensamiento va a llegar como una base
con un costo con un contenedor y me va a
permitir hacer mi camino a conseguir ese
objetivo
quisiera pedirles al todo en este
momento que cierren los ojos por favor y
les quiero pedir que vayan hagan un
chequeo de con qué tipo de casa ustedes
más se sienten identificados
y manteniendo los ojos cerrados quisiera
pedirle también que revisen qué es lo
que ustedes sienten que les hace falta
mejorar para conseguir los objetivos que
tienen en mente
continuando con los ojos cerrados les
voy a leer una frase de víctor frank que
dice así
a un hombre le pueden robar todo menos
una cosa la última de las libertades del
ser humano la elección de su propia
actitud ante cualquier tipo de
circunstancias
la elección del propio camino
pueden abrir los ojos
ruiz baumeinster señala que existen tres
componentes para lograr un objetivo
el primero es establecer una motivación
para hacer el cambio y fijar la meta
clara esta motivación tiene que ser
personal tiene que ser tiene que
provenir de lo más profundo de su ser
monitorear el comportamiento que lleva a
la meta de aquí yo también añadiría
también que no es solamente el
comportamiento sino que también les va a
servir mucho identificar cuáles son los
pensamientos que por lo general gatillan
que usted desee sabotean no para
profundizarlo sino que simplemente para
identificarlos y ustedes tengan noción
de cuáles son los pensamientos que
gatillan
cuando ustedes flaquean
y tercero ejercer la fuerza de voluntad
que es una pieza vital para lograr la
meta
ahora bien para finalizar quisiera
darles a ustedes algunos tips para poner
en práctica en el día a día el primero
de todos cambia la manera de desear
hazlo en positivo
verbaliza lo que quieres para ti desde
el quiero no no desde el no quiero sino
que desde el querer para ti porque
cuando verbalizamos nosotros estamos
creando una realidad entonces si
queremos crear una realidad que sea en
pro de nuestro bienestar entonces desde
un querer por ejemplo quiero conseguir
este objetivo quiero superar mis temores
quiero sentirme mejor
potencia al máximo lo que eres y vales
sé tú mismo no abandones ni tus pasiones
ni tu identidad ni tus principios
variedad tus propias convicciones y no
la de otros
muchas veces cometemos el error de creer
firmemente lo que los demás nos dicen y
empezamos sin querer a crear una última
gen distorsionada de lo que realmente
somos
atrévete a abandonar la zona de confort
abandonando la zona de confort si es
claro ustedes pueden salir un poco
lesionado moretones rasguños es cierto
pero el estar el hecho de salir de esa
burbuja ustedes van a salir victoriosos
porque van a adquirir la experiencia que
otros no tienen
y las herramientas para poder subsistir
en ella
proponte pequeños desafíos para ganar
seguridad confianza y autoimagen
y las piernas listas visualízate
logrando objetivos visualizar y
mentalizar cuando nosotros nosotros
solíamos hacer esto cuando los más
pequeños quizás muchos de muchos de
ustedes también han perdido esta
capacidad y
cuando éramos niños nosotros pensábamos
nos fantasía vamos con ser astronauta
con ser bomberos que se yo policía
presidente etcétera no muchos de
nosotros tampoco cumplimos eso pero lo
más importante es de visualizar es dejar
es sentir es encarnar
es dejarse llevar porque la medida que
estamos haciendo eso volvemos a darle
importancia a nuestro objetivo y
volvemos a considerar que ese objetivo
nos va a traer un bienestar
para nosotros personal muchas gracias
[Aplausos]